una noche de diversión que se convirtió
en tragedia estas son las consecuencias
de un tiroteo en el centro de tel aviv
un hombre irrumpió en la calle de
dizengoff una zona que normalmente está
llena de personas que van de fiesta pero
cuando se escucharon los disparos se
desató el caos se puede ver justo detrás
de nuestro restaurante las familias y
los amigos estaban sentados cenando y
bebiendo y de repente el terrorista se
acercó y les disparó el terrorista huyó
y ahora estamos haciendo todo lo que
podemos hacer
las autoridades dicen que más de 1000
fuerzas de seguridad israelíes fueron
desplegadas en tel aviv en las últimas
semanas ya estaban en alerta máxima tras
una ola de violencia mortal entre
israelíes y palestinos aunque los
motivos del atacante no están claros
israel dijo que el tirador era un
palestino de cisjordania tras subir del
lugar de los hechos el agresor se
escondió cerca de una mezquita de jaffa
donde las fuerzas israelíes lo
encontraron tras una larga persecución
por tel aviv el atacante fue abatido
durante un intercambio de fuego no se
sabe si el agresor actuaba solo o si
tenía cómplices
el primer ministro israelí naftalí
bennett prometió que todos los
implicados en el ataque pagarán un
precio a nafta maniquí en office pull up
no hay y no habrá límites para esta
guerra estamos concediendo libertad de
acción total al ejército al servicio de
inteligencia de todas las fuerzas de
seguridad para derrotar el terror de
loiu mic ballot la mil jamás
el grupo islamista palestino hamas
elogió al atacante pero no reclamó la
autoría del hecho